proteins carry out the labor in our
cells so we really need to know what
they do and how they work the key to
proteins is their shape because that
dictates their function they can take
many different shapes scientists call
these folds unfolded a protein is a long
string of amino acids there are 20
different amino acids in each one of
them has its own chemical behaviour when
a protein folds up you get a long and
tangled piece of spaghetti with all
these different chemical functionalities
on it it's not exactly like spaghetti
because it's 3d shape evolved over
billions of years to do very specific
jobs if you can understand the minut
details of the structure of protein not
only do you get insights into their
function you might be able to change
that function so researchers have been
trying for many years to solve the
protein folding problem can we just look
at the sequence of amino acids and
predict how a protein is going to fold
you could take the amino acid sequence
plug it into a computer and see if your
algorithms are good enough to make sense
on how it might fold you can use x-ray
crystallography or other techniques to
image a protein structure but that
hasn't been done for very many kinds of
proteins a couple of decades ago folks
asked a separate question could all the
genome sequence data the 3 billion
letters in our genome and the billions
and all the other genomes out there
could they scan that code which is
separate from the amino acid code of
proteins and learn anything about how
proteins mifold
the DNA in our genes codes for RNA which
is translated into proteins so there's a
relationship between the four-letter DNA
code and the 20 letter amino acid
sequences of proteins because a protein
wraps around in many different twists
and turns the sixth amino acid in that
chain might end up next to the 18th
amino acid if they end up next to each
other researchers realized there might
be an interaction between the pair that
is critical to the shape of the protein
and therefore its function if that's
true then a mutation in the DNA that
changes one of the amino acids must be
accompanied by another mutation to the
other member of the pair to preserve the
interaction in essence they Co evolved
well if you can log maybe a hundred or
more of those cases of close by
neighbors and 3d space based on looking
at many genome sequences then you can
plug that into your folding program now
that it has all these tight constraints
it gives a much better chance of getting
a really accurate structure and it works
the upshot is scientists can fold lots
of proteins that they never could before
that's important because it will give
new insights into how those proteins
work beyond that researchers have been
steadily improving the ability of
computers to model the shape of proteins
and this now enables them to design
their own proteins making things never
seen before in nature the most obvious
application is medicine they can target
very specific parts of the flu virus
with a special built protein enabling a
vaccine that works across flu strains
they've designed proteins that naturally
assemble into tiny cages that can
deliver different molecules in the body
or new materials like engineered
surfaces that self-assemble
could be used in solar cells and
electronic devices you can go in a
thousand different directions